[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want today we have soy and
cat is back as well
you just said you're a food god what
makes you at the godly level well
sometimes when people worship you it
becomes like a godly level
absolutely i'm gonna worship you if
you're only five foot six though oh well
you're five foot six
we're the same height no no we're not
okay we're not joking don't get too
excited oh
i'm actually i'm actually five five five
four
no five five and three quarters oh i
thought you were gonna start your
dominance and say you were five seven
i thought yeah sometimes yeah sometimes
you're bigger like taller
i know i look taller in videos i feel
okay yeah so people look up to you for
food
sometimes and other times they look down
to her because she's like short
yeah it's a weird feeling no uh because
i think like when
when i mean god i mean like people
always ask for like recommendations
like where should i go and i'm usually
like blinking out because i feel like
when you talk about work so much
you like food's like always like in my
brain so i try not to think about it uh
are you sick of it now you're just like
this [ __ ] turkey leg
sometimes yeah really yeah it's like
it's a weird feeling because when i
first moved to la like there were so
many different like food places to try
and i was like a kid in a candy shop and
now i'm like oh my gosh like
if i have to have to eat somewhere i
have to film it and it's like a super
like anxious
right you have to like vlog get anxious
when you film out in public i don't feel
anxious because i'm just eating but like
i have to think about like okay how can
i make this into content how can i make
this it's not fun anymore
like eating is not fun anymore for you
it's like work yeah when i'm not filming
it's fun though like when i don't have
to think about like hey how do i make
this like the best video possible it's
like
great when you're when you're eating now
do you ever feel like
guilt though because like sometimes like
if i'm like i'm a family vlogger right
so i'll vlog whatever i'm doing and then
like sometimes i'm like this is my day
off it's cool like i'm just gonna hang
out with my family be like a real person
but then you end up being a real person
and like really good moments happen
you're like oh [ __ ] should i go get the
camera you know and then you just kind
of get caught up in this thing and then
that would have been a good contest yeah
and your mental health kind of gets all
attractive and you feel guilty sometimes
you feel that or not oh 100
yeah i don't think anyone can like share
so much of their life and then the
moments where they don't like want to
share it's like
it's like how do i balance that right
yeah yeah like when i went home to
florida
i've never featured my mom before and i
was like oh i want to feature some
vietnamese recipes for my mom
i filmed some videos they hit like
hundreds and thousands of views and i
was like sick
crap no it's like a good feeling but
then also like now people want
more of these videos and now all your
time with your friends yeah and then my
family time
yeah and i'm like no my mom is a
sagittarius she loved it she was like oh
people love me
i want to be in more videos but then i
was like i'm not stressed about like mom
you have to get these angles
but it's you know it's like you can just
say sad
we we know it does sad
we're that good so you think you'll get
to a point where you like tell your mom
not to go to work so she could be part
of her channel oh that's the that's the
goal but she lives in florida
so it's kind of like i can only visit
her right now and trying to figure
everything out but
that's the ultimate goal i mean i want
my mom to have like a restaurant where
she can cook whatever she wants
you know i've had some ideas like maybe
i should make a cookbook but then use my
mom
like give her opportunities you know
yeah that's sick that's the best thing
she makes
um she makes a solid pho like i've i've
heard it's the best fellow anyone's i've
ever eaten
no [ __ ] your way i'm gonna have to go
and check that out yeah come to florida
all right come to florida you guys are
all welcome
really what's so good about her fun uh
the love
she puts a lot of love and energy into
it and she makes like a giant pot yeah
and like she serves it to the church
people and everyone just loves it
there's just so much like
love and she serves you every bowl hand
by hand but yeah she puts so much time
and effort like she doesn't sleep in the
middle of night
to check on the pot it's like a lot of
like little details let me ask you this
okay
so like you know what it's like to turn
your love into work
right and then how it turns into this
mixed
area now right now friends with benefits
right so what if your mom her special
ingredient is love
but when she opens up a restaurant that
love might turn into the same thing that
you're dealing with corporate that's
that's what i always turns into guilt
yeah
or msg yes i mean she's good though
she's not bad for you yeah
that mystery is delicious but she like i
i was like what's your dream mom and
she's like
i want to share my recipes with everyone
i don't want to charge anyone for the
restaurant and i was like
she sucks at business i know she wants a
soup kitchen
i know and then i was like i was like
you know i'll run the business for you
then she's like oh then i'm not taking a
salary and i'm like
how is this like how is this possible
but i feel like as long as your heart is
there
and someone else focuses on like the
business aspect it could work out
she's like the artist basically right
and you're gonna give her a place
to kind of do her thing but you're the
predatory manager
that's gonna milk the hell out of her
but she lives in florida it's not
exactly free to live there what does she
do
uh she does meals yeah oh okay yeah she
does but she should be in cooking huh
100
her heart's in cooking but her
technician does she want to do nails for
free
i don't think so she probably would
honestly she would
she no she's like a super like kind
woman she's like the nicest person i've
ever met my life wow she just wants
people to feel good
yeah it's like throw cooking on through
nails yeah because i used to have an
insecurity as a kid like
my mom does like service work yeah and
then she was like oh my job is like
beautiful i get to make people happy and
beautiful like she's like
the kindest person ever and i wish my
dad was more like her mom because my dad
was a service worker as a car dealer
and he says i've been called racist but
remarks by
every single culture because i know how
to cuss in tagalog
spanish english like you name it i've
been called every single thing for doing
the wrong cards out to people he's like
i've been called [ __ ] in 50 different
languages
he sounds like a worldly man yeah he
knows all the languages
a lot of culture he's also the nicest
guy bart's ever met
the nicest there's a little hesitation
in there
yeah yeah damn do you think it's
your love for food and all that like
passion came from your mom
i would say so but also like i grew up
in florida like i mentioned so there
wasn't much part of florida they keep
saying florida
like people always ask me to lay but
like jacksonville
oh okay yeah well i don't live in
jacksonville middlebury you're a big
jags fan
sometimes okay when they're winning yes
that sounds right you're a real jax fan
then middleburg yeah
i actually live in middlebury but i say
jacksonville because it's easier closest
is that on the what part of the shoe
north center okay on the
on the west side or the central north
central yeah
like a dick yeah it's like a drooping
dick yeah yeah yeah kind of see like a
hockey stick yeah
i could see a dick like a flaccid one or
like a broken leg
like this okay okay i see so like the
top of the dick
okay okay but not quite there god
it's a good place to be yeah there's not
like a there wasn't a lot of culture and
stuff so
i didn't really eat out and i didn't
even know what like mexican food was
until
i went to college and i had chipotle
which is not mexican food but to me i
was like whoa this is cool a burrito
that was the first time you had a
burrito was in college it was chipotle
oh
is that insane you lived in florida you
bought there's
some shitty burritos cuban food but
that's like south florida like
oh yeah miami is [ __ ] but in every place
there's like just some chain players or
some shitty i don't think you've been to
middleburg
it's a little bit different what do they
got like gator sandwich
yes i've had gator so you had gator
before you had a burrito yes
oh [ __ ] it's so interesting what other
weird meats do they eat in florida i'm
sure it's weird but gator is probably
the biggest one that people talk about
is it chewy is it gamey
it tastes like gator it's like a fish
chicken it's like it's like a chicken
fish
chicken fish chicken fish how frog kind
of tastes like chicken yeah yeah like
that yeah like reptile
tasting chicken kind of like poultry but
but less
tougher than frog oh do you like it
um not a huge fan okay not a huge fan
okay yeah
i want to eat it you should try yeah if
chick-fil-a made
gator gator witches i would eat them
witches
gator sandwiches sandwiches no
chick-fil-a
oh chick-fil-a because they they did a
root they do a really good job with
chicken breasts
yeah and then when i tried gator um i
was eating it and i'm like oh i can see
this thing could dry out fast yeah it
does because it's like
it's kind of like chicken breasty fish
but then if chick-fil-a got their hands
on it i think they can make it really
really good when you live
next to disney world and you go to
disneyland for the first time you're
like whatever
i think i went to disneyland before i
went to disney world really because i
don't really live next to disney world
middleburg again middlebury orlando's in
the middle middle
no it's not like north yeah anaheim
it's like a three-hour drive in
middlebury
is there like a fog you can't like leave
like we should google where middlebury
is so we know where
it is i want to know where not to go
yeah middle burrow or bird
burg oh middleburg yeah middleburg i
mean if you have a town called middle
bird though
it's one of those like in the middle
somewhere of nowhere yeah
basically yeah there's you see more cows
than you do people probably
it's like that how much what's the like
uh i guess like diversity like is it
just were you the only vietnamese family
there or
basically yeah my am i like college my
high school
graduation i think like and i was part
of the ib program too so i was like
super small
we had like maybe like three or four
asians including me
and my whole entire like class basically
tell your mama why the [ __ ] did we move
here
well i didn't know any better like i
couldn't be like hey why why am i here
you know
oh was it weird for you when you came to
an area where there were more asians
oh 100 whenever you're like oh there's
more of me yeah when i went to la i felt
a little too comfortable
really like i was like whoa like i can
like be like everyone else and not
really like stand out soon you're not
like the token asian yeah
that's a weird feeling i'm originally
from dallas i spent some time in orlando
uh but when i first moved out to la i
there's this sense of like
satisfaction of like uh i can rest
easier or something like because you're
amongst your own kind but it's weird
though because it's like
i don't know these people they're
strangers to me but for some reason it's
like ingrained in
our psyche to think that okay we belong
now
exactly yeah it's like an easy feeling
but also uneasy because then people ask
you like
where are you from and then i'm like
florida and they're like oh did you hear
about that story about the zombie guy
that eats the soaps
and i'm like yeah cool story dude yeah
it happens
do you guys rep him do you guys like
that's our guy on the flag
i mean yeah he's he's a holiday legend
yeah we sell it holiday that's also a
zombie
there's a flag of him biting a [ __ ]
crocodile and [ __ ] it's a classic story
yeah it wasn't really scary when we
heard in florida we were just kind of
like oh
florida people doing florida [ __ ] just
another day in florida
today's video is brought to you by
fields and guess what babies
cbd is not about what you feel it's
about
what you do not feel because when you
take feels
you get to chill the hell out and you
don't feel the anxiety
you don't feel the stress you don't feel
the
maybe drinking a little bit of too much
of caffeine because that's kind of like
what i do
you know what's crazy is usually like
before you know we used to do shows and
stuff
um i actually like that nervousness
so i like the anxiety because it helps
me like i don't channel some sort of
like creativity
but the part that does affect me like
recently i had a really big meeting
um and it's gonna be early in the
morning on zoom and
that was one that was weird because i
was thinking about it all night going
into the night
so like six o'clock seven o'clock eight
o'clock
for the next day yeah so like if i'm
well rested
yeah i can handle anything i could do
we've done like 1000 people shows 500
people shows and i'm cool and i actually
thrive off of like having a little bit
of anxiety
but having bad sleep because i've been
thinking about it messes me up so
i took some feels a couple drops
underneath the tongue and that chilled
me out so by like 10 10 30 i was able to
kind of get drowsy and i felt relaxed
and peaceful
and i was able to have a good night's
sleep and then the next day the meeting
went
really really good so that really helped
me out too
that's awesome yeah so if you guys don't
know fields
is a premium cbd that's super hassle
free and it goes straight to your door
and it's pretty easy the way that you
think it is you just
like bart take a few drops and go
depending on what you want there's
different doses to it for different
peoples
different feels for different kills
seals skills yeah i think that also they
have technical support too if you don't
know what this stuff is about you don't
know what's right for you
you can give them a call be like yo i
don't know what i feel
yeah i weigh 100 pounds or i weigh 300
pounds what do you think
they help you on that yeah and that's
the cbd hotline
from fields yeah so if you want to
become a member today go to fields.com
that's with the f-e-a-l-s
dot com slash off the record to get 50
off plus free shipping that's feels.com
off the record
for 50 off plus free shipping thank you
fields
that's the feels baby just another game
is everyone just [ __ ] at driving in
florida because i always hear florida
man stories and i'm like everyone's
probably on math or drunk or
whatever no not really
yeah i don't i'm i think i'm a pretty
good driver but my friends wouldn't
agree but
but floridians though because i know
californians are [ __ ] drivers already
but i hear all the crazy stories about
florida people and i'm like they must
just suck at everything
well i have a theory on why california
drivers are bad drivers why go forward
because everyone in california isn't
really from california
true so i think like you have all these
different driving techniques styles
defensive aggressive texan like
floridian and it's like even
world international drivers yeah so then
you're kind of like dealing with all
these different types of people driving
differently on like really bad highways
with really bad traffic
but i do have to say though like
californians are pretty nice
for a major city like like they let you
win like have you ever tried to drive in
like the east coast
they are aggressive they so mean man
what's the best restaurant on the earth
if you're a food god
yeah you're about to die what's your
last meal last meal
right now give it to me oh food god on
the top of my head right now
i had a really good tsukimin ramen
experience in little
in tokyo itself yeah and like tokyo
station
i'm talking about something accessible
oh
i was like little tokyo that's my let's
go like which carl's jr do i go to
the one that they call hearties okay
that's true yeah
what is like really good place i get
this question a lot and it always
changes
i really like um i don't know if you
guys have been to
sun moon some dogs that sounds familiar
they do the
giant galbi gym with the cheese on top
and they oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's like for some
reason it feels really homey to me
yeah i love food like that stews yeah
well it's like you have to use two there
too
but it's like a giant meat platter it's
like short rib or something
yeah sure and then they cover it in
cheese and they [ __ ] torch that [ __ ]
and it's also like a korean barbecue
sauce right yeah you get a sweet kind of
kind of sweetness to it and then you
have all the banchans is it called
gamjitong or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
like the little side korean dishes
kimchi and all little salads on the
sides
and like you can share that with so many
people and they're open 24 7. so
like you can get it at any time even
during the pandemic yeah even during
epidemic
illegally legally or does it matter oh
they were doing delivery
oh yeah you can deliver you can get it
delivered like how haircut places were
closed but like yeah where they clearly
heard there's some places yeah i heard
there's some k-town places that were
just
open if you knew who to ask wait how did
they do the torching did they bring it
to your house and go
oh they're just like on your own they
just give you a side of cheese and
they're like on your own so you've got
to buy the blowtorch and then yeah
damn i microwaved that [ __ ] yeah it's
not the save you got to torch it man
it's so good yeah it's so you've missing
the most during the pandemic like when
you're
at home because obviously you probably
were in florida
i was here so you couldn't eat probably
half of your favorite things right well
i kind of adapted i started eating in my
car
oh so you would just take it to go or
something because i was like oh small
businesses still like kind of need help
yeah and i was like oh let me like eat
in my car because i i do think it's like
hard
not eating inside because food just
tastes so better fresh yeah immediately
immediately so i was like oh how do i
support businesses and also like
you know eat good food and i was like oh
i have this like whole like car set up
situation
like a car tray and i just eat in my car
oh you were the trisha paytas route
yeah like trisha pitas did my route true
just kidding
carter is next level white trash [ __ ] i
love it
i love it that's great i love it yo her
friends though i saw this video
where they came out with the freaking
whole outdoor eating system in the car
like they pulled it out it was like a
whole picnic thing
but we have tables too i have tables and
chairs in the back of my car right now
like wwe tables yeah like full dashes no
but wasn't there one where it was
connected to
oh yeah verissa has the one that's like
a picnic table yeah
like an umbrella on top too yeah that's
pretty intense
that's pretty cool i was like that's
pretty smart because then you could just
go to any restaurant and then pull up
and you just have a freaking outdoor
restaurant yeah i was eating in a
parking lot at a second and then like
the staff saw me and they're like oh do
you want any drinks as if they were like
serving me and i was like
sure and then they came up with drinks
yeah did you think they're going to kick
you out like you can't do it i did
because like one time the security guy
like drove by in his little cart
and i was like i feel like in situations
if you just smile and you're just like
hey what's up
the guy was just smiling back and he
just continued driving his little
security never happens to me it's like
you have a table that's
a that's a pirate ship like in your
house
with the umbrella that's the weirdest
thing i've ever heard
i love it they i think they appreciate
like any type of business right now
of course yeah true so you're not
originally from la when did you um come
out here
2014. and was it to pursue the foo god
world
i graduated and i didn't know what to do
so i worked at like a youtube mcn
for like animation frederator studios
okay i don't know
oh it sounds familiar they used to make
like uh dexter's lab powerpuff girls
like all the cartoons
yeah and i helped um them build like the
biggest mcn for like animation channels
oh and i think we had a movie deal with
them but then that guy ghosted us
oh i wasn't a part of that remember
there's a guy that came here no parts of
it he had a we had a whole slideshow yes
he made an animation and then it was it
was very structured it was like this is
a pre-production phase this is the
budget and how long how much
time then production was going to be
like this and we're like oh cool it
sounds like pretty easy and laid out
and then we're like and then they go to
you and then we talk to them we're going
to be the voice actors and then we're
going to go okay cool let's do it and
then it was just
nothing after yeah it kind of makes
sense they're kind of like a startup-ish
vibe
and while i was working there they like
cut like 75 of staff at one point
because
that's probably what happened he got cut
when one of their deals didn't go
through for like their venture
capitalist
situation and then like and the next day
i came into work and like everyone was
like
hey like most of our team is going to be
let go and i was like one of the people
not lego
and it was like one of the worst like
survivor guilt feeling where you're just
like [ __ ] like even my like vice
president got that going oh [ __ ]
you got survivor guilt for me i'm like
only the strong survivor
i clap as they leave the door yeah you
should have been like me buddy
you are weak you are weak no i felt bad
cause i was like i was like yo like i
might lose my job next you know
it's like a [ __ ] you know yeah yeah dude
mcns are like that though it's like
every day russian
it's like that and then i ended up
working at disney um
producing for like their digital stuff
and then i
the pandemic happened and i was like
dude i'm like so depressed like i can't
just like
keep doing like jobs even if i'm good at
them and so i just quit and i just like
did food blogging like
you just quit the job it's not a crazy
good job really great my dream job
did you have a silver pass silver pass
yeah i can go to just any time
yeah is it still no no when you quit
it's gone
it's gone after you quit because you're
especially kicked out of the disney
family
yeah i guess i could rejoin if i wanted
to so you didn't come here for
like to be a food blogger 100 not
interesting
it didn't exist probably when you were
100 not yeah i like
i started my food blog because i didn't
have any friends all i did was work all
the time
and i was like okay what can i look
forward to and not feel like super
stressed
i was like let me go to different
restaurants and just like post pictures
online to share with my friends and
family
and then for some reason like i met
other food bloggers and it started like
a whole community thing
and it started growing and then i guess
people like the way i present food i
think my point of view is kind of like
i don't know i'm not an anthony bourdain
i'm not a gordon ramsay i'm not a chef
but i knew i do know what i like like to
eat and i want to share it with people
you know
so that was like the whole i guess point
of view that i come in with
yeah i noticed that like you don't come
with this ass
like this pretentious aspect of food
it's more like
these are these cool things that i like
and i just want to share and then so
when i'm watching your stuff
it doesn't feel intimidating like i
should be this like
[ __ ] five-star chef that knows
everything like and i feel like
there's a whole different part of food
where people feel like they need to be
experts and stuff right
did you meet her online no um we
actually met
through a mutual friend he hosted like a
sushi party
and then she was there and then we have
mutual friends in the food world
and i think like the influencer food
world is pretty
small like you know one of our business
partners june she's pretty prominent in
there
and like you know they already know her
and so it just
felt like through friends of friends we
kind of
already feel so comfortable in here yeah
do you ever feel super judged when
you're taking pictures of your food
because everyone's like ah people taking
pictures of their food again yeah but
you're like this is my job you dumb [ __ ]
sometimes i try to like i used to say
that to me when people give me like
weird looks i would be like
oh like do you want to learn more like
all that stuff but nowadays i feel like
everyone takes pictures of their food
and not just like food influence so it's
normal
yeah i used to be like super extra
though like i used to like climb on top
of tables and
oh [ __ ] in front of everyone in front of
everyone because bring lighting to or
or i used to i used to because i was
like oh but now like since epidemics
happen i feel more stuff in my
car yeah but i have lights on my car
that i have set up for like nighttime
filming
but in general it's like not as weird
anymore before it used to be like
why are you taking pictures of your food
just eat it and i'm like well maybe i
don't want to eat it maybe i want to
savor the moment and then eat it did you
have a team with you like setting up
helping you set up lights or was it no
it's just me
yeah everything i do is just me like i
edit i film i produce everything's
myself
wow that's dope i love it so much
control we also have an easy setup for
carport if you ever wanted to do that
uh yeah it's it's on my list i always
see it i don't know how they film this
it's actually something i like one of my
favorite genres carporn
uh specifically roadhead
i've never heard of this perhaps you can
tell me okay i'll share some links
his favorites
[Music]
you